hey everyone and welcome back to yet
another episode of watching the Watchmen
and today we're actually looking at
Watchmen you know we go on these
tangents on the show which are great we
go into various different graphic novels
we go into shudder Geoff Johns Doomsday
Clock as well but today we are with all
faithful alan moore dave gibbons and
let's not forget John Higgins as well
and also got death with me as I always
do deaf a coma I'm still standing yeah
yeah yeah I've been listening to that
revamp Elton John album Tom Wright I'm
just making my own version of it hit me
about them and big big we don't really
want to put too much out there deaf but
big film companies getting in touch with
you your videos are too popular
yeah I've just had an email from a film
company basically saying stop spoiling
our movie will you take your video down
so I don't know how I'm gonna handle it
yet yeah stay tuned stay tuned and you
know I want to say as always get in
touch with us we don't really get any
emails ever we get the occasional one
here and there I would like to start
some sort of critical correspondence I
would like to have it like a few email a
few podcasts out listen to that always
get complaints cuz they spend too long
on the emails so many people want to
talk to them unfortunately we don't
really have that here but maybe we can
in the future so watching the watchman
pod at gmail.com get in touch with us
there as well we're on Twitter we never
use it I I always get notifications for
our Twitter of like people to follow and
stuff and it's never anywhere following
us because just like Orin Winick oh is
it like at Watchmen pod I want to say I
think that's what it is I'm not quite
sure but I mean might as well you'll
find us on there we'll put the link in
the description below as well check out
all the old episodes that we've done but
yeah we're back on watchman and we're
back with issue a old ghosts um let's
just leap straight into it death and as
always we're talking about the covers of
these things and I know it's something
we're always noticing [ __ ] things
we've never seen in Watchmen he's you
know a masterpiece on a Hieronymus Bosch
type level and just struck me the other
day
the statue of Hollis Mason which is a
adorning the front you know in gratitude
is what it's saying you know
people are thankful of what he's done
but could you not also read it as
ingratitude but yeah people don't give a
[ __ ] what this guy's done yeah it's sort
of it shows like the the change in
attitude really with the ingratitude I'm
a poet and I do know it Tom yeah
these heroes were once heralded but are
now shunned and so it's a clear
commentary to me at least on Vietnam the
super heroes are sort of the soldiers
who went out to fight and die for their
country and they've come back in a spat
on made homeless left to live in these
two port rooms that they're not like
where Hollis Mason lives it's not the
the apartment of a hero at all it's a
shack and it's not even the Love Shack
because all he ever gets his visits from
Dan who's a fat guy gone through a
midlife crisis you know I mean it's not
like it's not a nice place so a dad dude
completely take it like in gratitude
that they're not grateful at all and
it's almost like I don't want to point
these out now cuz we pointed about a
billion times but the smoke on the cover
right it saw the Watchmen blood dribble
across the desk yeah definitely always
and I just loved the way the bronze
statue really reminds me of Metropolis
mm-hmm and it has this very thirty's
feel to it and it yeah it's a nice
little trophy
and the fact that it's polished as well
you know it's not a neglected relic so
yeah it's a in dan dreiberg Snite cave
you know where there's just stuff in
shelves door Halas still clearly
treasures this and we see this kind of
like it's quite noisy because you have
the book on the side and the newspaper
framed and then you sell like a six-pack
or a cancer or been loosed and you have
sort of the the plastic there behind him
and the little owls the little Russian
doll owls and this sequence we're always
gonna complement the mange eggs you know
I've got so much time for John Hagee and
Chad John Higgins who came on the show
and absolute Jen you know awesome
episode I'm sure most people listen to
it and he's lighting in these sections
because obviously Hollis is speaking to
you know Silk Spectre here Sally and
we're going back and forth
Bente I'm not gonna dr. Manhattan cents
button literally in a time zone sort of
sense and I just marvel at how he
commands the night and day in the panels
yeah it's brilliant you like Doomsday
Clock like in this you can totally tell
the time differences yeah as they jump
across also there's that black and white
photo of the Minutemen Doomsday Clock
colored in I don't want to keep slugging
a house bomb people are sick of it um
yeah just brilliant the way that it's
just walls basically but you can totally
tell the time differences you can tell
the different characters even without
really seeing them it's colored so well
there's a clear indication of difference
and it's really well done there's even a
gradient color on the the front cover
Tom I don't know if that was digital
yeah yeah if the that was what you
managed to do at the time but yeah it's
just a really nice use of color this
entire issue is to be honest there's a
brilliant scene where Rorschach breaks
out the prison and it's just flashes of
red and black and yellow and it's just
incredible and you know these the two of
them are reflecting obviously it's
interesting more plays with time and
legacy so well and throughout this issue
we we're seeing their descendants
effectively go on an adventure so it's
nice to see both of them sort of
speaking about this world and we see the
Tijuana Bibles you know on on Sally's
beds there and you see the sort of them
the the the old images as well is that a
smiley phone on the fourth panel in the
receiver are we just looking 2d yeah no
nothing you oh yeah it's something like
that I just kind of like a stitched
mouth and and stuff like yeah the the
Chia skoro
of the whole thing is fantastic and then
sort of you know you're reminiscing on
their worlds and we have a little teaser
here as well just going onto the second
page of you know what will happen
layover sort of the onslaught these
Halloween adventurers and it's lovely to
see them in costume and of course no one
dresses as superheroes in this world no
which is crazy they all dress as pirates
and ghosts and devils and stuff yeah
yeah yeah but it's nice little touches a
very more is very good at world
building in this mmm and you can get
only so much from every single panel I
even the little nostalgia bottle is
there reminiscent yeah yeah tell you
what if Jeff John's done that Tom you
would be fuming yeah he's a hack
get rid of them but they talk about the
past in a way that makes you realize how
much they miss it and the sadness of old
age is really like at the the center of
this issue it's called it's called ghost
stories and it plays a lot on the past
haunting you I think yeah yeah well it's
called all ghosts actually I think those
stories actually haunting yourself there
I've got from one instant emails written
film telling us to take me and in
explain video downtown but I don't want
to slightly one-up who could it be
and you know talking of slagging off
death I was thinking going through this
maybe this issue might not hold too much
weight for you there's a lot of black
freighter here my friend there's a lot
of black freighter yeah I mean it's
alright it's kind of not entire pages
it's just very briefly interspersed into
all the panels and so it wasn't like too
jarring for me um yeah it's alright yeah
it's and you know juxtaposition everyone
we're gonna say the word a billion times
I'm afraid there's no other useful
synonym comparison may be right there
joking the Scimitar of it so we learn
about the news vendor Bernie his wife
dying or Bernard or whether he's called
and then you know we have the the family
departing is well Jeff Inc is really
nice all of it is really nice and he
also talks about lots of stuff happening
underneath the waterline which I guess
could be construed as more sort of
talking directly to the reader and how
you know there's hidden depths to
Watchmen and you know a lot of people
don't dig beneath the surface narrative
and miss a lot I suppose yeah maybe
maybe like Mars pretty much letters all
of his books with so much subtext yeah
it's really difficult to kind of analyze
what deliberate and what isn't even
almost you know I've become fascinated
recently we've leave
extraordinary gentleman and there is
this website that breaks down each issue
and it is is mind-boggling every single
character is from a like obscure
Victorian literature all right you know
what I mean or like the brand of
something will be a prime minister that
had an influence on it's like it's I
can't believe how in-depth it is it's
like nothing I've ever encountered
before like you know and I sort of like
that littering history sort of stuff but
it's just like wow you know it really is
you know magnificent and we get from
before the Internet as well Tom's
just new Google reviews like you did
yeah nowadays you just find some Dickens
character and throw him in there
wherever but you know yet more is just
and what are the things we get death
with this issue getting onto pages four
and five now and throughout the book a
lot of you know inventive technique with
the paneling you know a lot of stuff
yeah I love these super panels that sort
of convey movement but maintaining one
image it's really inventive oh it's
brilliant um I love seeing down and
laurie in the cave as well too it's very
reminiscent of Batman definitely there's
this huge computer and gadgets thrown
about and everything soap half worked on
and it sort of symbolizes how
everything's falling apart but we can
put it back together and become whole
again and which I think Laurie and Dan's
Arc symbolizes so it's nice that their
entire arc is also depicted in this page
and what Gibbons does with the the nine
panel grid is just incredible in this
issue just that there's so much
experimentation going on but it still
feels part of one piece and he's not
going mental with it but it's it's just
really well put together and thought out
and it gives a great feeling of
landscape and environment damn it
definitely does like even at the top
corner of page for the top right you can
see that sort of mech suit that you
really would miss if you weren't
scouring the images and there's the
paper on the chair as well and I like
how Laurie speaks about the hoverbikes
which we see and you Dan slowly piecing
things together like you talked about
them coming together but the plot in and
of itself you know he's starting to
realize all these different you know
subsidiaries are tied together and
even even the angle from within Archie
looking out to them as well that's
gazing on and they sort of touched on
this in the earlier issues but as a
motif it's fantastic
oh yeah it's brilliant and I just love
it when you kind of get a tour of the
the heroes hideout it's always something
that's fascinated me and like Batman
obviously my favorite hero they've done
some amazing stuff with his his hideouts
where you can see like the Batmobiles
from different eras and in all-star
Batman and Robin Gimli actually did like
a three-page spread and that kind of
folded out and it was just the entirety
of the Batcave and it was great to see
like the 1966 Batmobile in the 1989
version and it's just a really nice
place to be in seeing this personal side
of the character and seeing all the
technical aspects of it it's sort of
like The Wizard of Oz and when you
realize the wizard it's kind of just a
man behind like a computer controlling
everything in villains Minds night owl
will be this like Wraith character and
it's great just to see like they're
almost the magician's tool chest is that
right I don't know but yeah just to see
how everything kind of works on a
technical level yeah yeah and I
completely agree I love seeing the
superheroes lair I think in all-star
Superman as well when we see the
fortress of solitude quite a few times
throughout that yeah you know the fact
that he keeps the key outside as well
but no one could pick it off yeah yeah
just yeah well we need to do something
on all-star Superman it always seems to
come up when we're talking I think most
people realize is one of the best
superhero comics ever but to make too
many nerds have reviewed it on YouTube
death it's like we're just stepping on
old ground I feel just call it end and
explain Tom yeah and it'll get millions
of views so and I think Laurie in this
section as well talks about John popping
up where you don't expect which you know
clearly is tying into later on when dr.
Manhattan intrudes in here but yeah we
get into the prison which is some
fantastic sequences I especially love
when the guard is being compromised and
in the left of the panel we just have
this unmoving henchman just staring him
down and here on face
he's cracking in fear and you know slow
acceptance and the composition by
Gibbons is expert yeah they do some
absolutely brilliant pacing here and
with the panel's like this entire issue
I think it's when the art and colors
kind of really combined to make one
amazing piece yeah and just the use of
shadow the way everyone's got the kind
of distinct color the silhouettes
throughout and it's absolutely brilliant
the color is very abstract like Purple's
yellows blacks but I like I know when we
talked to John he said even much prefers
the digital and modernization where
you've coloring things but I prefer this
abstract use of color and it's really
inspired and really drives the emotion
of the work yeah yeah but of course you
know Higgins did done this so I Coralie
disagree with him he hates it but
everyone who works on Watchmen apart
from Dave Gibbons hates it
the I love panel eight here so just the
one where we see Rorschach full-on and
like oh you're right abstractly look at
that doorway look at the purple and the
black yeah it doesn't really look like
anything but you completely know what it
is and the saying is terrific and you
know here as well we see a different
side of Rorschach like we've known
Rorschach's very canny and we do see
this later as well when he escapes from
the cell but he's just uncompromising
isn't he there's there's no fear at all
he knows he's gonna get out of here and
he's gonna have fun doing it and what I
love about this is like even though it's
written down you can totally imagine how
Rorschach saying it and it's completely
perfect like even though he's completely
stoic
it's just you can tell he's delivering
them in a way that's really winding this
guy up like mr. figure he's called and
Rorschach just doesn't fear anything and
he's completely uncorrect he's
completely unbreakable and it sort of
highlights in a nice way that
Rorschach's put away all these people um
and but mr. figure when he was put away
by Rorschach he would have been put away
by like the nicer version of them yeah
and he's obviously figured us and
realized he's not facing the same
person because if he was he wouldn't be
alive in these sort of taunting this
modern Rorschach and you're just kind of
sitting there knowing how it's gonna
play out you know this guy's got no
chance against them and you're just kind
of wanting to see exactly how Rorschach
gets out of this yeah and the whole idea
is well that this this dying man
is basically the straw that broke the
camel's back something's gonna kick off
which is fantastic as well and love the
way so that I love how mister figures
smoke as well sort of in circles
Rorschach from behind the bars and yeah
and then we also get a sort of splash at
the bottom of page seven which again is
given sort of exploring it we probably
have this before in other issues in fact
I just turned to a random issue and dr.
Manhattan when he's on Mars creating the
kingdom you sort of have that as well
Adam I love the effect here as well like
Rorschach isn't sort of staring out in
despair or what's happened it's it's
more apathy and patience yeah he's just
waiting for his moment really um he's
just like a master tactician and he
knows there's no point in getting wound
up he's heads constantly in the game
waiting for how things are gonna play
out he's like a sniper he's just sitting
there waiting for his shot to come it
didn't present itself there but he was
still giving like enough grief that he
knew the guy would get wound up from it
and you know emotion it can be very
paralyzing and especially in combat
going on a figure of I've seen a movie I
think I've seen it in Star Wars so like
don't you don't let your anger take
control of you because if you lose
control then it's gonna go badly for you
and Rorschach staying completely in
control and he's getting this other guy
more angry in order to make him lose
control and it is just completely
manipulating him into what's going to
happen later in the book and I don't
know about you but like just mr. figure
as an entity that's all small guy
surrounded by the big guys it's a very
sort of classic villain archetype isn't
it in comics like I've seen this many
times and I like how that's what more
uses here something quite familiar yeah
definitely
really really well done and it's just
it's a nice play on comics again more
deconstructing the genre and it's just
it's making Rorschach more and more
likeable I think as well the more we get
to know the actual person the more we
can kind of be like yeah this guy's a G
and you know talking of subtle
confrontations the next sequence which
are we again I think I think these
issues out of this world really I think
this sequence is terrific like reading
this the dialogue leaps off the page I
can almost imagine this being filmed
like the way they go back and forth from
the sort ways that Detective fine you
know obviously knows something's up with
a tenement fire and has his submissions
of who Dan is and the subtle clues it
but there's just lots of stuff that's
like again under the service under the
water line you know so when he's talking
about him smoking for example you do see
that ashtray but the yesterday it's not
necessarily pointed out to you you sort
of have to know what cigarettes look
like in the watchman world to realize
that that's an ashtray and even when
detective finds leaving and he looks at
the coat hooks and see there's two coats
there which clearly indicates that
someone's staying there you know there's
just lots of green very cool stuff yeah
it's really good really well-thought-out
you know it's it's attention to detail
that a lot of artists and creative teams
would miss and I just love how he's kind
of he's happy he's sort of warning a
missus saying how no one really condemns
someone who would do a tenement like
rescue people from a tenement fire but
beyond that it's kind of like crossing
the line a bit here and what I love is
that they discuss the calendar and how
the policeman says some people pick her
head out what the next month is but Dan
says he doesn't and again it subtly
shows that he lives in the past quite a
lot yeah and there's an amazing bit
where they look at the next month and
it's an eagle taking out an owl and
obviously the eagle symbolizes like the
American government and what happened to
night owl if he goes back out again and
that they're happy do that and do things
to a certain point but beyond that you
know it's it's gonna be no-holds-barred
and to me this is a very clear influence
on the joker's speech in the dark night
and it's nice to say that the see that
there's always this rocky relationship
with police and vigilantes and they're
just one step away from being a freak
and getting hunted
I by the people they're trying to work
with and help out and it's just yeah
it's really really tense scene really
well done and yeah it sort of shows how
the these heroes they're not like what
most people would think comic book
heroes are then the police don't love
them there's there's always that thin
line between them and the media as well
we seen overexpress here we never
actually get to read spirit of 77 which
in of itself I had to do a bit of
research exerci is that actually a
reference to exactly reference to the
spirit of 76 which was the zeitgeist in
the American Revolution this being 1776
okay what a famous painting as well from
1876 you know just all about sort of
sovereignty and breaking free of chains
which you know you see a lot of in this
issue the idea of liberation both
Rorschach being sprung from prison and
then you know more metaphysically Laurie
and Dan becoming their quote-unquote
true identities and you know the back
matter that we get as well from the new
frontiersman is very much in you know
antagonizes with Nova Express and yet
this whole thing at the lock as well
being changed for a think the third time
this yeah get his law or not yeah yeah
and the catering packs of the sugar as
well which is really intelligent is
really cool way to think about it like a
super having to buy in bulk for his
vehicle in case he rescues people and
clearly fine knows what's up and and
what's he say here about the the
lumber-room as well like he's trying
just trying to get down there like you
can smell it yeah he knows and he's it's
nice that he gave him this warning
there's obviously some mutual respect
there I don't think it would give the
same to Rorschach and but obviously
knows night-owls like a very sensible
guy you knows he he's not went psychotic
and he's just trying to warn him out of
probably respect and that they obviously
have a have kept it close I and I mean
they might even know about Hollis Mason
and how friendly is with him and they
just want to kind of be like look yeah
you're on your final warning no more no
more hitting children and women and
cutting
dogs it's open I know what was you
every scenes tied together in Watchmen
so dancing suddenly we have a deadline
leads us straight into the you know the
the newsroom and I really like I don't
know this is the first time it's
happened we're actually seeing the you
know what we've read at the end of the
book being assembled before our eyes
yeah it's a really really rich world
building nature here that I like and um
despite this as well don't know if this
is important but I've seen Watchmen
everything is kind of important death
it's cool that their clock has Roman
numerals ya know sort of how the issues
have Roman numerals and how we always
see the clock counting down as well yeah
as in the inference above any finger you
know beyond itself but it's still really
cool and we're sort of learning a little
bit about max O'Shea who obviously did
all the black freighter stuff and um why
is Manish drawing the Beast
like what what why is she doing I don't
quite understand why she's actually
putting out there she might just be like
just doing it to a girl you know I mean
why do people do hour-long podcasts
every month you know I mean Thomas a bit
sad when you think about obviously there
must enjoy it so yeah I should pretty
sure she's an artist isn't she she is
yeah yeah so just let her draw tom yeah
and we get you know we get a lot of
insight into this world into these eyes
that would be sent across and you know I
loved the in the top three panels of
page 11 seeing the boat get closer which
reveals that it's tied to Adrian and
yeah it's just it's so clever that when
it's far away it's too blurry to see and
then for one frame it's in the correct
distance and then it's too close it's
just a sense of movement to me in comic
books
it's just genius that's really good and
I like how this these panels juxtapose a
new new frontiersman and the layout as
well so you've got the the conspiracy on
one side and then you've got the
conspiracy coming true on the next what
you don't never see that why did you
ever realize that of course they do
mirror each other perfectly I never even
saw an idea yeah that's brilliant yeah
it's really good but obviously the some
of the conspiracies that the new
frontiersman talk about just make
think my god these guys are just
conspiracy theorists like think Jews run
America and I think the Nova Express is
funded by communists it's flat earth
type stuff Tom but it turns out that it
was flat on the next page yeah
and then underneath I should say as well
we get some nice stuff of you know
Archie being charged up I guess and then
having the real superhero stuff having
the map of where they're breaking into
and yeah donning everything and yeah
it's um I guess you know you can see the
sea goals as well as seeing like a black
freighter sort of it I'm pissed off that
I didn't realize that they have read
this so many times of what didn't I see
that before yeah I mean more yeah again
yeah again yay again and I guess that
the creatures being covered underneath
that tarp alling so yeah so from her
angles you can see it a little better
than we can
yeah the first time you read this you've
got absolutely no idea what's going on
even if you've seen the movie you
obviously don't know about the big
vagina alien yeah um so it hints to a
bigger plot but doesn't paint it out and
it leaves a big mystery of like what the
hell is this woman drawn you should just
draw on something I don't know you know
I mean it's it's really well seeded and
it's not like in Doomsday Clock where
they've got a mystery going on but it
takes up three pages it's just there
it's six panels and you can probably
skip it and feel like you've not missed
anything definitely definitely and you
know we get some lovely stuff here with
the you know Hollis getting ready for
Halloween you know mentions of people
about the war and what brains do they
have as he's scooping them out and like
I did write a note but I'm like I don't
really agree with my note that I wrote
like my note was like him cleaning out
the jackal Islands kind of like Laurie
and Dan cleaning out the Archie and
getting it ready but I'm like that's
tenuous that's that don't respect that
death don't respect that's got a smiley
face on the pumpkin and a drip over a
toy it does it does of course it does
yeah I just yeah as well yeah that is
that is great and um the distant dogs
nose as well from the bottom just nice
bit of movement there like you know how
a dog would behave as you saw assemble
that which is nice and um you're lots of
like there is a lot in watch
any Doomsday Clock there's a lot
Watchmen of news reports and hearing
them over here but I think it's done
well and I think you know the world
buildings top-notch and the what sort of
falling to [ __ ] a little bit at the
newsstand isn't it's a lot of
disagreement yeah I mean I'm not that
like interested in these characters be
honest I don't know like I just cracked
my eyes kind of gloss over on these
sections or that there's probably bits
I'm missing and but it's just you know
someone makes a homophobic gesture and
the lesbian character kind of kicks off
about it I'm not saying that I'm
ignorant to gay rights you know what I
mean - I - when I get that in I know it
sounds like it's a are to the gay rights
a bit just give it I'm not saying that
Tom please please don't tell anyone I've
said this don't it's what men but yeah
no I get you yeah but yeah these
characters I don't know I think it's
because they're so normal and mundane
that I kind of breeze past them a bit um
yeah and it's also where the black
freighter happens as well so it's like
yeah just get past it you know on pages
10 11 and now these ones 12 and 13 and
indeed 14 15 we have anchored at the
bottom just these wide images of RT
going out searching which I just think
are fantastic I think Dave Gibbons eyes
is terrific here I love Archie rising
high above them and you know you could
argue that the sort of this the smoke
from the from the Kade Reid and a black
freighter is kind of reminiscent of you
know Archie rising above now we get into
the prison sequence which I might think
is one my favorite moments in the whole
of Watchmen yeah I just love all of this
sort of stuff and I just love seeing how
ingenious and gruesome Walter Rorschach
is like you know him cutting this guy
sorry he's sorry him binding this guy
this fat man as a sort of padlock and
using him as a human shield is grotesque
but genius oh it's brilliant and this is
like the main action set piece of like
the book for me and it's just so well
thought out
I love how calm and stoic raw [ __ ]
Rorschach is he's just taking these
people out with such ease
and you know he's getting real joy and
glee from it even if his face is
completely expressionless it uses wit to
take them out and it's very methodical
and well conceived and it just gets
really gory really quickly and mr.
figure realizes he's in big trouble I
put that in your book more put that
phone in I'm as good as muerto maan what
you are you are yes yes been on the show
lately more like he not only fixed you I
don't know if you've noticed I'm I've
sort of realized a certain way to go
viral and they'll tell you what it's not
doing [ __ ] I'll and more impressions so
just cut them out and speaking of KY ink
you know that the guy is I mean his
front is slashed and gallons spray out
onto Rorschach who you know I mean this
is genuinely like water off a duck's
back for him being spread by fat guys
blood isn't it yeah and more so good at
the sounds cool like to khh what it
would sound like and him bleeding out as
well and him just sort of you know if
they come and get me like raw shanked as
you know I guess I don't have weapons
here on a sort of normal level they
could just shoot him like a rat in a
cage here but they have to sort of think
on their feet like he does and these
splash panels as well I should say a
fantastic they're like something out of
2000 AD they have these giant images
with lots of stuff going on I love the
phantom you can see the cars driving
towards the courtyard and then the sort
of the face that the faces in the
screens in RT as well sort of zooming in
and you see all the buttons in flow and
he's terrific
that's brilliant and this is where
Higgins goes crazy with the colors like
I absolutely love this bit where and
they try and short-circuit the door open
and everything just goes yellow green
purple black red
it's just increase in tire like pieces
just brilliant it is I've never seen a
action scene colored like this before I
don't think there's been one since it's
just absolutely incredible yeah and you
know aren't you flying over the top this
is one of the biggest images in Watchmen
isn't
because it's taking up two-thirds of the
page yeah it's big Archie and he's here
and he's got like spotlights shining on
him like spotlights or something that
you only ever really see in comics
yeah like bat-signal stuff like that you
never they're always incredible like the
way they cut across the sky though um in
just the way it all positions the the
light towards Archie and even like the
little you can see there's a tiny break
of light going just above Archie um and
it's just where the spotlights being
like passed over right a bit and there's
such attention to detail yeah it's it's
brilliant yeah there really is and you
know the guys or the firing at it and
the book that bullets ricocheting across
and you know they're in superhero mode
really like we're a long way from a
tenement fire this is some some real
serious [ __ ] and Archie screeches what a
cool feature yeah oh yeah and it just
completely takes everyone out basically
they get a free run rein of the prison
and just by turning on these massive
speakers it's a non-lethal way to like
beat criminals as well which I love yeah
because you could easily just pull in
and just gun everyone down and but he's
using these non-lethal tactics to get in
the prison and get people out and you
know I like how they say they can hear a
siren coming through and it's again just
just builds that sort of sense of pace
going forward here yeah and you know
Rorschach kicking through the toilet and
electrifying the guy is you know it's
similar to when they break in the
apartment and you know he does
eventually get caught but he gets his
way out pretty much most of the wave is
you know grappling gun and what does he
have like fire and very basic tools yeah
I love how figure he becomes a child
isn't he like you know running away like
the face he shows I reckon his facial
expression is quite similar to baby
Walter Kovacs expression when he sees
his mom with the job no that's really
really good spot yeah definitely um he's
horrified at like seeing this beast that
Rorschach's become yeah he was expecting
like a a play fair crime fighter
who'd like arrested people instead of
killing them in the large fish cold
mental is just murder and everyone yes
and he's it's not even cracking it like
he's not even wincing or anything this
is face there is he's like looking over
the bodies he's just kind of like you
didn't care even night he walks he walks
through the prison he's not like trying
to like hide and stealth his way out
he's just walking out very slowly he's
completely in control of the environment
and it's it's like a nightmare yes yeah
it really is like just looking at it now
it's just so it's a good just like the
Terminator Tom it is it is like the
Terminator shout out um Robert Patrick
is that the guy from Terminator yeah
yeah cuz I've just re-watching Sopranos
at the moment and he's in series - oh
God and he was in x-files as well he was
yeah he was known as Mulder's
replacement and I not good John Daggett
you know like um I thought it was good
did you longer to be fair how much
x-files for a long time I was a little
bit younger Vince Gilligan from Breaking
Bad that was that's where he made his
bones was jnanis yeah mmmm Bryan
Cranston on that show as well the
so-called driver thing know where they
measure to do things and no you bloody
Holly embarrassing I'm coming up with
these accurate facts Tommy just throwing
anything and basically Bryan Cranston is
a guy in who if he stops moving and his
head explodes right up so he's
constantly driving across state and
obviously he's not obeying the traffic
laws and he gets Mulder in the car with
him I mean Mulder's kind of got a he's
in trouble but it's where and Vince
Gilligan and Bryan Cranston first work
together pushing for a long time I was
referred to a man who's got billions of
useless pop-culture references in his
head uh yeah Rorschach has time to make
a bit of a gag here at his own expense
as well talking never disposed of sewage
water sewage with toilet before obvious
really
yes yeah yeah great stuff as well -
nothing you sleeping it should be called
the comedian brochure
these books
all the puns should be called The
Punisher me a Pawnee superior yeah and
you know we get them going into the
world as well going into the prison
again John Higgins is coloring is outta
control here I love this sort of you
know so sepia tones of almost
Marchioness you know some yeah of a
worldly sort of thing here Rorschach
with the pool of blood walking away his
corpses behind an old electric wire and
the tied wrists and and and the the
fallow leg and I like how they find
Rorschach quite quickly but more again
putting something out there that you
wouldn't consider if you only know
someone in costume than they are a
stranger in real life yeah definitely
that's true and I'd like how they talk
about they think Rorschach's genuinely
going to the toilet and then Dan so he
talks Dan talks about like how criminal
one's got away cuz he needed a piss yeah
and I've all I have always wondered
stuff about that because I remember
Christian Bale was talking about when he
was in the Batman suit how it took him
like an hour to get taken out the suit
just to have a piss Jesus and I was
wondering like yeah if someone actually
was wearing a suit in real life and
tightened down criminals there would be
a point where like Arnie caught the
toilet the conduit
isn't the room he's my Kevin Smith
Batman comic cacophony yeah where he
makes battler won't piss himself yeah
did that hang all the bags may it was
crazy I'm not even that bothered about
it I'm like yeah fair enough
and it's because a fireman once said
that when the heat hits you you to liked
old Kevin Smith when he hits you and
you'd need to urinate like if you're in
the shower and just the heat hits you
you need you need urinate and basically
some accounts with Batman where you just
need to piss basically but about the
battle fans there were few min Tom will
have a none of that they were making
their own podcasts about it right they
were talking about Kevin Smith like how
you talk about Jeff Jones yeah like
unlike Kevin Smith a lot as a person I
just I've read a bit of his graphene or
he's alright I am read much of it to be
on
but what's he Kevin what is that mark
that he does Batman I'm Batman with yes
Marvin Marvin on it that guy is like the
go at summing up the themes of stories
it's crazy how good is it like me yeah
so yeah then they they get him out
essentially and um is it employed that
why heapsort drowns mr. figure or cuz he
said yeah thanks
associate flush ism yeah yeah and and
then sort of blood pulls out as well and
we see them together and Rorschach again
is just Rorschach he talks about not
liking Sally's costume back in the day
but at Laurie's costume sorry back in
the day and the old toys and the killer
mask theory and I love that sequence as
well as Rorschach sort of them being
flown upward and then his facial
expression I don't know how to read it
slight despair perhaps or maybe it's
just the g-force of Archie taking him up
yeah I don't know but the guys just like
oh yeah [ __ ] this place I'm off and the
prison is just went [ __ ]
yeah well for that guy like the smog
Island okay there's dead bodies
everywhere
it's a nightmare yeah it's it's insane
and we return back to the image and yeah
I didn't really take it as the American
Eagle but that's the add totally great
analysis yeah I didn't yeah but whenever
the seagulls in comics Tom just a toys
America especially when was doing it
yeah he's having a slide dig our
American cousins oh yeah our American
friend a little fun fact you got your ex
falls fat that was the play that Abraham
Lincoln was watching when he was killed
really and John Wilkes Booth was an act
I knew the script and he waited for the
funniest joke in the play and then he
show him in the back of the head ruin
his day
yeah really ruined his day I read the
joke it's like it's like some sort of
it's like Shakespeare isn't funny really
anymore like it's dated some Oscar wall
stuff is actually really funny still
because it's just really cutting and
sharp our American friend I read a
little bit of it all my boy no that's
not age it's just like oh the British
art you know and it's just I said like
that Avengers first honest comic I've
been
for the past three months I'm here at
San Infiniti bore right yeah I never
tell you why they call it infinity Tom
it's never-ending I finally reached
about six issues of a comic a day and
I've been on that for two weeks and I
just managed to finish it this morning
and I knew I knew straight away like I
don't like this but I'm I'm accomplished
missed you know I mean yeah so I just
had to do it had a review thoroughly and
yeah and it was crap went straight on
eBay as soon as I closed a likeness out
of my sight you know they returned back
to the apartment back to the back to
sort of reality for a moment
John intrudes and I like how dr.
Manhattan just arrives you know and you
see sort of his arm in the mirror which
is called me he doesn't arrive in a
flash like they depart he can just sort
of assemble himself here and obviously
he is elsewhere in Mars as well but he's
just there there's no need to like
announce it fancifully a so yeah and you
just realize how weird he is as well
just by the way talks in this like he's
got he's completely detach from humanity
at this point to me just the things he
says he's trying to explain to Laurie
how they need to have a conversation on
Mars which like it just shows how weird
he is like she can't get her head round
about how they haven't had the economy
and getting lost like trying to explain
it mm-hm and he's explaining how the
rules of time were different for him so
he knows that he's gonna have a
conversation with her in an hour so he
thought he'd come early together yeah
and she said well what are you talking
about why Mars and he's like because
that's where we're gonna have the
conversation
yeah it's baffling equally baffling is
why he's reading overexpress cuz Shirley
just knows all this like him reading a
magazine isn't it taken any information
it's like when he wears a suit you know
to the interview and stuff he's just
sort of caring to this world but it's
cool to see him back you know and I like
the way that Higgins gives you the pink
background as well we have the face on
which yeah provokes Mars as well and
Laurie says dais Navy is on
then with our pink background yeah maybe
so you might have a duplicate on Mars
yeah yeah yeah yeah we just say I am now
amaz yeah it may be dozen Laurie as well
as very many she talks about deus ex
machina you know God from the machine
which was a tendency in Greek and Roman
tragedy to sort of involve God at the
end to sort of you know resolve the
riddles of the drama and it's just an
easy way of doing it and you see all the
time in movies yeah there's terrible
aesthetic like Toy Story 3 is quite a
good example where the crane sort of
saves them before they're all burned
alive and all they were just doing loads
of movies don't they like whenever a
character just randomly shows up to save
the person from being killed
it's just lazy right it is but I like
the fact that more like you know
acknowledges it at least it's a bit
contrivance but but yeah we needed to
have we need to have for Manhattan back
here and then they depart and then we
get sort of like a smoking Nova Express
which I'm not quite sure what the
inference is that of that I think it's
more just like it you know that's been
fruit the hot stuff the smoke of time
and it's sort of sizzling there and Dan
looking quite pathetic quite podgy not
the hero he was 20 minutes ago as he's
looking down yeah
Zeus like he's come into contact with
the ex hasn't he and he's just yet human
about it you realize as they are crow
I'm not that hot and you know this is
also a joke suppose with with the mob
building the rabble building you know
they themselves realize and they have to
depart and it's quite exciting actually
as the apartments swamped and they just
escape down the tunnel yeah
oh it's great a great escape yeah it's
really good like I love the SWAT team
rushing in and trying to like shoot it
as it's flying off down the UM let's
just say I got away yeah yeah and
they're too good for these guys come
there were always better than the police
fax thanks and we get lots of cool
images here with the black freighter as
well I do like the sort of skeletal face
staring deep down into the abyss of the
ocean yes you know the fish sort of
picking a in stuff it's very evocative
stuff and you know lots of stuff here
that we've touched on a lot of times
before where what's written in black
freighter is mimicking what's going on
here
and one of the saddest scenes that sort
of concludes the issue death is Hollis
sadly being mistaken for Dan and all the
people descending upon him and one of my
favorite things in Watchmen is the
juxtaposition there I go again of him
being beaten to death and then the old
school night owl like you know you can
almost see like BAM when he's sweating
people in the house and he's yeah dog
with the mask on the stomach so
bittersweet so poignant about that well
it's clear like the guys in this crappy
little shack is in E Tom and he's like
he's dead he's been throughout every
time he's made an appearance he's talked
about punching someone hasn't he yeah
and he wants to go out in a blaze of
glory this guy and and he saw it it's
nice that it has his life flashes before
his eyes he kind of remembers all that
the good times and they do this expertly
in the film in the extended cut where
you get like Moloch and all the villains
kind of returned to his apartment and he
imagines he's fighting them and it's
just really poetic and it's the way that
he wasn't late his costume at the bottom
smiling as he yeah and it's just yeah he
says trying to put a brave face on this
but you know we see smiling there as he
goes out yeah and then he gets his head
kick caved in with a statue from the
start and all you see is this smashed
pumpkin on the floor oh my god yeah yeah
and I mean arguably the saw silhouette
of the statue similar to the the
Rorschach mask yeah no definitely yeah
and yeah it's just oh man just the
inference as well of sort of him being
killed by the statue it's it's so poetic
you know it truly is in gratitude and
then him being discovered at the end and
yet again we have the blood splatters
which we can see across the portray and
stuff like that hey this is one of the
best issues of Watchmen death I'm gonna
say it I think it's one yeah definitely
it's going to when they cross over the
line and this is like then the point of
no going back yeah
it's point of no return right now and
they're just yeah it's it's all gonna
start kicking off in a second they've
all kind of been walking about their
apartments talking about like
oh this could be happening they've been
meetin in offices to to discuss the mass
murder and this is where it's all gonna
kick off now and it's just great that
the boots from got massive pace to it
now I can imagine at the time like
wanting to see what's gonna happen next
yeah yeah it was can you imagine reading
Watchmen in real time yeah we crazy if
you were a fan of this sort of [ __ ] must
have been like the most exciting thing
ever like yeah but everyone slugged it
off like we did with Doomsday Clock and
then it got amazing well the thing is
that one podcast back then like all the
world were just like educated comic book
nerds in like yeah Forbidden Planet and
[ __ ] like that and we we close of a
quote by Eleanor far-far John who had to
look up she's died in 1965 she was an
English author of children's stories and
plays and satirist as well obviously
someone more knows deeply and we're
completely ignorant on but yeah the
quote death how do you read into this
quote on Halloween the old ghosts come
about us and they speak to some to
others they are dumb yeah don't worry
you know um to me kind of did once again
highlights how your old ghosts come back
and haunt you
mm-hm and you know if you live a good
life then maybe you're not haunted by
them I don't really don't how come ya
come clutching at straws here yeah yeah
no I obscure that when it's on Jeff
John's level of obscurity that one yeah
probably had old ghosts in it and yeah
but let us know in the comments below
you know please subscribe to the channel
as well I should say please share this
with your friends who are maybe in to
watch women be getting into Watchmen you
know go through the archive as well on
the podcast got loads of great episodes
and discussions on there and we close up
with a new frontiersman article not too
much to say here again it's incredible
how Morcom inhabit all these different
voices so convincingly in this case you
know the far-right press that are sort
of lambaste in the the pot heads of Nova
Express you know they're talking about
being in favor of the Ku Klux Klan we
get a sort of alternative USA here we
hear
the retaliatory bombing of Beirut which
obviously yeah never happened in the
real world and just an appeal really to
the superheroes and we get an image as
well a caricature that reminds me a
little bit of the Victorian cartoonist
James gillray and I love this where the
sort of all-american soup here and all
the voices around him and we see someone
John Q public has a flag for the Keene
act right okay yeah it's a very detailed
yeah looks quite racist as well yeah
yeah yeah it's one of those caricatures
and that you see like of Jewish people
and stuff that the Nazis kind of its it
about yeah yeah there's a lot I take
from this I love how like the paragraphs
aren't aligned
they're very sort of slapped together
and very amateur and it sort of reminds
me how Oh conspiracy theorists think
they're so intelligent sophisticated and
awake when they're literally sitting in
the bedroom coming up with these things
that are going to take down the world
and yeah it just shows the amateur side
of this and the photos that aren't there
as well and and the more yes that are
still in play and yeah yeah it's
terrific and we do get some conspiracies
as you say and probably the most
important article is the final article
here the missing persons article where
we learn about all the people that have
gone missing you know max O'Shea the
surrealist painter here a Minesh hard
science fictional for James Trafford
March all these sort of ideas they tie
it to the Cubans which obviously has no
relevance upon some things are teased as
well that become really important like
you know the missing head of Robert
Deschenes the psychic and yeah you know
great stuff without goes without saying
really another fantastic closing issue
closing part to the issue yeah and
what's great is that their conspiracy
theories did have some grounding to them
and but it sort of speaks to the apathy
of the people because it was rough I in
front of them the whole time like the
put the jigsaw pieces together you know
I mean Tom oh yeah bit bit of a Doomsday
Clock reference for you there I know
it's on your reading list
and yeah maybe maybe if it was a jigsaw
puzzle they would have gotten it but
it's a really nice way to end the issue
so yeah it's good good and you know I
should say dear listeners we are me and
ever going to try and make bones about
it we're gonna try and do this a lot
quicker than we normally do so we were
back sooner rather than later for
another episode of Watchmen and then
nothing Doomsday Clock will probably be
out in the interim between that and the
following one should be number 10 def as
ever this has been great man any any
closing thoughts go watch my videos on
YouTube yeah yeah if you haven't watched
them or I'll kick your head in
I mean it's you are like you won that
BuzzFeed right now yeah it could be
crazy recently I've said like I said
earlier I've got my formula now I mean
it just all seems to be going taken off
of her about a thousand subscribers in
the last week that's crazy
let's hope that the love hour-long
podcast yeah it's not rubbed off to any
of our [ __ ] no use on our last video is
weird yeah so losing views on this but
everything else up going strikes terror
yeah yeah well I mean you know thank you
everyone for listening as always it's
always a pleasure to do this and you
know I'm sure people and they appreciate
it and we definitely have fun talking
about this as well but death this has
been great Barry thank you man yeah
thank you it's a good night from me it's
a good night from Queen
you